che cos'è l'eccellenza è un traguardo o
un percorso è qualcosa che appartiene o
pochi o che tutti noi possiamo avere
esiste un eccellenza diversa da quella
che abitualmente immaginiamo è
un'eccellenza che va oltre il traguardo
e che appartiene a ciascuno di noi
perché dentro di noi in modi e forme
diverse e più la usiamo più si consolida
e si espande e se ne sta lì seduta in
noi ad aspettare di essere vissuta e
sperimentata che cos'è e la capacità di
mettersi in contatto con noi stessi e di
riconoscere tutto ciò che positivo
dentro di noi le nostre qualità
le aspirazioni le capacità d'azione le
nostre potenzialità e più abbracciamo
questa eccellenza più liberiamo la
nostra capacità di esistere ed è una
meraviglia quando ero antropologa ho
lavorato e vissuto in molti paesi e ho
interagito con persone di diverso genere
ho affrontato situazioni difficili e
come molti di noi me la sono cavata ci
sono state però delle volte in cui mi
sono stupita delle incredibili soluzioni
che il mio corpo alla mia mente avevano
escogitato per salvare me stessa e per
aiutare gli altri
ed è stato in quei momenti che stare in
ascolto fidarmi e mettermi in contatto
con ciò che vivevo di positivo in me mi
ha permesso di scoprire le risorse e le
capacità che avevo dentro è stato in
quei momenti che io ho capito che noi
siamo più di quello che crediamo nel
gennaio del 1998 3 milioni di persone
nel sud del quebec vivono un'esperienza
drammatica
io sono una di loro per sei giorni una
tempesta di ghiaccio si abbatte
sull'area lasciandoci in completo
blackout senza riscaldamento elettricità
a temperature sotto zero sotto il peso
del ghiaccio chilometri di tralicci
dell'alta tensione crollano a terra
anche gli alberi crollano crollano sulle
case nelle strade sulle macchine come
nei film dell'apocalisse ci troviamo per
strada con molti altri
ricordo camminare nelle strade al buio
con una torcia il cielo è così pesante
che sembra caderci addosso
ricordo lo scricchiolio macabro degli
alberi che stanno per cadere e sono
terrorizzata non riesco a vedere dove
sono sento la gente urlare e provo un
inconsolabile bisogno di protezione
i giorni che passano sono giorni di pura
sopravvivenza quando il blackout finisce
la vita riprende poco a poco ma non per
me rimango con un profondo senso di
desolazione e di totale aridità e mi
chiudo sempre di più per giorni e giorni
mi sveglio la mattina cercando un motivo
una ragione per andare avanti e mi dico
ma com'è possibile che cosa è successo
come posso aiutarmi che cosa deve
rivivere dentro di me ma c'è solo
silenzio
non ci sono parole ma sto in ascolto
stone e ascolto e ho fiducia che prima o
poi qualcosa deve succedere fino a
quando una mattina mi sveglio pensando
di essere un piccolo fagiolo secco un
piccolo fagiolo secco mi visualizzo
all'ora in cui fagiolo e mi fido perché
viene da me
così nella mia immaginazione
lo metto nella bambagia per farlo
crescere e da quel momento decido che io
vivo la mia vita con un fagiolo
immaginario in tasca e gli do pure
dell'acqua ogni tanto i giorni diventano
settimane la desolazione e il silenzio
si trasformano in curiosita ma che cosa
sarà mai
sarà un fiore c'era un albero mi accorgo
anche che cresce un senso di
responsabilità verso quel fagiolo secco
le settimane diventano mesi il fagiolo
secco è sempre lì ma io sto sempre in
ascolto con il mio fagiolo in tasca la
curiosità diventa pazienza la
responsabilità diventa accettazione
della realtà così com'è almeno non sono
sola col mio fagiolo in tasca fino a
quando un giorno mi accorgo che c'è
qualcosa di verde che spunta da quel
fagiolo quel fagiolo oggi è una quercia
quello fu un momento di eccellenza
avevo avuto una piccola intuizione
positiva
un segnale interiore a cui avevo dato
fiducia avevo ascoltato un mio bisogno e
mi ero fidata ed avevo riconosciuto
quello che provavo dentro qual è allora
il metodo per vivere questa eccellenza
speciale è semplice sta in ascolto
fidati e mettiti in contatto stare in
ascolto significa aprire gli occhi ed
accorgersi di quando vivi una sensazione
positiva perché questo significa aprire
le porte alle tue risorse profonde alle
tue qualità perché se ti senti
coraggiosa e perché il coraggio dentro
di te se ti senti onesto paziente
flessibile o generoso e perché queste
sono qualità che è dentro di te che
parlano di te e di chi sei veramente ci
hai mai pensato
le tue sensazioni positive
parlano delle tue qualità e invece noi
riconosciamo subito quando ci stiamo per
arrabbiare quando stiamo diventando
nervosi siamo inflessibili impazienti ed
è più facile stare con queste emozioni
negative e queste sensazioni fino a
quando sbagliamo o danneggiano la nostra
salute ma quante volte in un giorno ti
accorgi che vivi una sensazione positiva
quando per esempio fa qualcosa di bello
per la tua famiglia o qualcuno ti
sorride o prendi la decisione giusta o
inizio nuovo progetto o ascolti la
musica o tutto quanto sembra andare
liscio
quante volte in un giorno ti accorgi
qualcuno di voi potrebbe dire molto
bello quello che stai dicendo
ma la vita è dura e poi è veloce e
questo non bisogna dimenticarlo è vero
ma è anche vero che noi siamo nati con
profonde risorse dentro di noi e questo
non possiamo dimenticarcelo e stare in
ascolto significa aprire le porte far
entrare in modo decisivo
queste risorse dentro di te e significa
riconoscere chi sei veramente nella tua
essenza
quante volte facciamo delle cose
straordinarie e nemmeno ce ne accorgiamo
e quante volte diciamo non ce la farò
mai e ci dimentichiamo delle nostre
aspirazioni ma sai che cosa sono le
aspirazioni le aspirazioni sono qualità
che bussano alla porta e chiedono di
nascere e di essere vissute ma ci pensi
le tue aspirazioni sono le tue qualità
che chiedono di nascere e di essere
vissute è un po come quando vogliamo
suonare uno strumento perché abbiamo la
musica dentro o come quando vogliamo
sviluppare un progetto perché abbiamo
spirito d'iniziativa e sai qual è il
vantaggio di tutto questo
il vantaggio e chi più di venti
consapevole delle tue risorse e più
queste si consolidano dentro di te è più
né scopri di nuove e più le puoi usare
quando ne avrai bisogno
il secondo passaggio e fidarsi
chi di noi oggi può dire di potersi
fidare al cento per cento
la fiducia oggi è una cosa difficile
non ci fidiamo delle persone tanto meno
del sistema
a volte non ci fidiamo nemmeno di noi
stessi e delle nostre reazioni la
fiducia di cui parlo è diversa e fiducia
nelle proprie risorse ed è fatta di
pazienza e di apertura fidati delle tue
risorse perché non importa quanto ci
vorrà
non importa quanto difficile dura sarà
troverai un modo per andare avanti
il tuo corpo e la tua mente saranno lì
ad aiutarti e quando senti una
sensazione positiva fermati stai con lei
riconosci la e sai qual è la chiave di
tutto questo la chiave è quella di
riconoscere che ogni momento è un
momento chiave per stare in ascolto e
fidarti perché in quel momento che tu
scopri cose che non credevo di essere il
terzo passaggio e ultimo è quello di
mettersi in contatto
questo è un momento cruciale perché è lì
che metti le frecce nel suo arco
quando senti una sensazione un'emozione
positiva si è curioso dai un nome la tua
sensazione e prova a chiederci che cosa
sto vivendo adesso esattamente che cos'è
e amore e felicità e gioia e pazienza e
flessibilità che cos'è costruisci la
consapevolezza delle tue risorse di
quali e quante risorse hai dentro di te
come fai a scalare una montagna
se non sai quali attrezzi puoi usare o
quali attrezzi hai a disposizione e mi
sento di dire anche un'altra cosa
l'ultima quando senti una sensazione
positiva prova a vedere dove la senti
dove nel tuo corpo perché le sensazioni
hanno reazioni fisiche
esattamente come quando ti arrabbi e ti
fa male lo stomaco o sei depresso e è il
respiro al minimo o hai delle
responsabilità che non vuoi che ti fa
male la schiena
molti fanno male le spalle o al mal di
testa ma che cosa sai di te e del tuo
corpo
quando sei felice quando sei in pace con
te stesso
quindi stai in ascolto fidati e mettiti
in contatto il filosofo americano
william burns
parafrasando aristotele scrisse noi
siamo ciò che facciamo ripetutamente
l'eccellenza dunque non è un atto ma è
un'abitudine
e allora vi vi gusta questa eccellenza
speciale che hai dentro di te farla
diventare la tua nuova abitudine e
vedrai che meraviglia grazie
il mio pensiero è tutti noi abbiamo un
fagiolo che vuole crescere